Is this friendship an abomination
in the eyes of the law? Or can
a sorcerer supreme and a reformed
supervillain find genuine connection?
"She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" wastes no time in
utilizing the vast powerhouse that is the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. Throughout the nine-episode
series, "She-Hulk" brings in several characters
and references from the MCU, placing them directly
in the path of the fourth-wall breaking Jennifer
Walters. After the first episode explored
the relationship between Jen and her cousin,
Bruce Banner, fans got a chance to see
Sorcerer Supreme Wong, Emil Blonsky,
Daredevil, and even several references to New
Asgard, Thor, and the love life of Captain
America. In other words, "She-Hulk" is acutely
aware of its position in a greater narrative.
With the finale of "She-Hulk," several new
elements have been introduced that could
be laying the groundwork for future
MCU movies and TV series. Perhaps the
greatest shocker in "She-Hulk," though,
is the introduction of Hulk's son Skaar,
which some fans believe may be setting
up a "World War Hulk" movie. Of course,
in the Marvel tradition, the finale
features a post-credit scene which
raises particular questions about the
future of some fan-favorite characters.
Although "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law" sets up
a battle among She-Hulk, Hulk, Abomination,
a transformed Todd Phelps, and Titania, She-Hulk
uses her ability to break the fourth wall and
enters into our reality, where she demands to
see "Kevin," which is a direct call-out to Marvel
Studios honcho Kevin Feige. After finding out
that Kevin is actually an artificial intelligence,
she calls for changes that will hold people
accountable for their actions. This causes the
brewing epic battle to be completely tossed out,
and instead both Todd and Emil are arrested — Todd
for hacking Jen's computer and phone, and
Emil for breaking the terms of his parole.
Considering Emil Blonsky's new outlook
on life and general Zen demeanor,
he accepts his responsibility and his
punishment of 10 years in prison. However,
the end credits stinger in the
"She-Hulk" finale shows Wong once
again using his sling-ring to open
a portal into Emil's glass prison.
One reason for Wong's continuing efforts to break
Emil Blonsky out of prison could be that Wong and
Blonsky are actually friends. In the third
episode, Wong appears on behalf of Blonsky
during his parole hearing. The authorities
want to know why and how Blonsky escaped,
and Wong explains that he did it, and even
though Wong offered Blonsky sanctuary,
Blonsky turned this offer down in order
to show that he's reformed. At this point,
the authorities point out that Wong committed
a crime by letting Blonsky go free for a time
"You realize that you've just admitted to
facilitating a prisoner escape which is a crime?"
"I must go."
Wong may consider Emil Blonsky an actual friend,
and since Blonsky is only being sent back to
prison for a parole violation, Wong couldn't
let him lose a decade of his life. However,
there could be another reason why
Wong decided to spring Blonsky again.
Prior to "She-Hulk," the Abomination's
last MCU appearance came with a cameo in
"Shang-Chi and the Legend of the Ten Rings."
As "She-Hulk" reveals, that movie's cage
fight between Wong and Abomination was part of
Wong's training. Wong required a worthy foe,
and Abomination happened to fit the bill.
There's no animosity between the two,
as highlighted by "She-Hulk" and its finale scene,
so it could be that Wong is simply thankful for
Emil's efforts in this department, or it could be
that Wong has the intention of using Abomination
in the training of other students. He could also
be making good on his original offer of sanctuary,
because it's probably hard to get somebody
extradited from Kamar-Taj. Or perhaps there's
even a chance for a future TV show centered
on Wong and his who's who of superfriends.
For his part, Benedict Wong has made it clear
he loves playing the character.
He told The Hollywood Reporter,
"I'm just enjoying playing this role and
where it takes me. In every single kind of
project that they invite me to be involved in,
it just pulls away another layer of the onion,
you know? You get to find a little bit more about
the eccentricities of the Sorcerer Supreme."
Now Marvel fans just need
to sit back, breathe deep,
and await the next appearance of the
Abomination and the Sorcerer Supreme.